[ music ]
>>Randy Nelson: One of the
things that we do at Pixar
and I know some things
about Pixar uhm..
is we use improv as a mechanism
of helping with collaboration.
And in that, two core principles
of improv have always guided us.
The first is, accept every offer.
So if an improv, improviser
says to you, "Gee it's funny.
It's raining a lot in here today."
You don't go "Raining in here?"
You say, "Well that's why
they gave us umbrellas."
It's an offer.
You don't know where it's gonna go.
But the guarantee you have,
is that if you don't accept
that offer, it goes nowhere.
So you've got a sure thing
on one hand, dead end,
or you've got a possibility
on the other.
And the other principle is
make your partner look good.
What a great thing.
So you know on a team, that
anything anybody says to you,
you're gonna get a
chance to plus that.
You're gonna get a chance to
have that be on the table.
And they're gonna try and make you
look good, not make you look bad.
At Pixar, what we mean
by plussing is this.
You take a piece of work.
You take something that you're
working on collaboratively.
And when it's given to
you, you don't judge it.
You don't go, "Ooh
this is pretty good.
Here's what I'm going to
do to make it better."
Or, "This isn't so good, here
is how I'm gonna fix it."
You say, "Here's where I'm starting.
What can I do with this?
How do I plus this?
How do I accept the offer and
make my partner look good?"
So at Pixar, we want people
who are good at something,
not just a little good
at it, really good at it.
And depth is a great thing.
It's in a sense, where
everybody hires.
It's the resume based hire.
You want somebody who
really knows that skill.
There's a problem with that.
Most of the interesting
jobs out there fall
into this category
whether it's true or not,
of being innovative jobs
in innovative companies.
If you're doing something that's
never been done before or it's hard
to imagine how you can find
somebody's resume that shows
that they're not only able
to do it, but deep in it.
NASA had this exact
problem when they wanted
to hire the first man
to walk on the moon.
Should have been a person, okay.
Times are changing.
So their first search was
this depth based search.
And what they found was there
were far too many people
who were deep, who were very good.
They couldn't use that as a filter
and they realized what they
wanted was not merely people
who were successful and in fact maybe
that was exactly what they couldn't
afford in their depth based search.
They needed to find people
who had failed and recovered.
Those who had failed and hadn't
recovered were not applying.
They weren't around anymore.
We're talking about test
pilots for the most part.
So that filters out one group.
>>Audience: [laughter]
>>Randy Nelson: So that
ended up being the way
that the astronaut core was chosen,
was they were looking for people
who had not simply avoided failure,
but rather those who had seen failure
and had figured out how
to turn it into something.
The core skill of innovators is error
recovery, not failure avoidance.
So in the depth based hire, we need
something that allows us to look
across that success in their depth
to see something about their ability
in terms of resiliency
and adaptability
to actually solve a real problem
that's never been solved before.
So what do we do?
Well of course we look at their
depth in terms of their resume.
But we also try and find some
parallel that's a predictor
of success in that way.
And what we've recognized is,
mastery in anything is a really
good predictor of mastery
in the thing you want done.
If you take a young person who
is the best skateboard person
that you've ever seen
or the best glass blower
or really good playing spoons,
you're going to find something
about that personality
if they're truly a master
that has set their mind in a way
that you can use in your enterprise,
whether you're an educator
or a business person or both.
That sense of I'm gonna get to the
top of that mountain, separates them
from all of the other
candidates almost instantly.
And you know, in the high pace of
what we do in school and in business,
there's very little chance that
someone's going to achieve mastery
on the job if they didn't get there
before coming to your workplace.
So you got to have it in
the can, not just I wanna
or I wish I or maybe I could.
But I've done that.
It's one of the great things
about the proof of a portfolio
versus the promise of a resume.
That's one.
Two, breadth.
Oh my gosh, we certainly
don't want one trick ponies.
We certainly don't want narrowness
that can sometimes be the
thing that you get with depth.
What we've gotta find, is
people who are extremely broad.
And the predictor there, we want
somebody who is more interested
than they are interesting.
Yeah, anybody can have a pink
Mohawk and enough piercings
so that wind blows, you whistle
without pursing your lips.
>>Audience: [laughter]
>>Randy Nelson: That's
interesting and that's easy to get.
Interested is tough.
That's a real skill and I'm
sure all of you have that sense,
somebody in your life who you just
always think of when you think,
that's the person I want to talk to.
Why? Because they're so bright?
Yeah they're bright.
But what they do is they amplify me.
They give me what I need.
I say, I've got a problem
and they lean in.
They don't say, "Oh
yeah, I got problems too.
I bet my problems are more
interesting than your problems."
No. They want to know
what you want to know.
They want to know what's
bothering you.
That notion of breadth also leads to
point number three, communication.
Depth, breadth, communication.
Communication involves translation.
If you are a technician and you're
trying to speak to an artist,
if you just emit tech, well we
all know what happens, you know.
There's a lot of eye-rolling and then
we'll try and figure it out later,
get somebody to translate that.
If you know enough art as
a technician to be able
to do the translation at the
sending in, so it doesn't have
to be translated at
the receiving end,
you may actually be communicating.
Communication isn't something
that the emitter can measure.
I can't say I'm communicating well.
They turn the mic on.
I think you can hear me.
But you can say, I understand.
So nobody can declare
themselves as being articulate,
but a listener can say,
I think I got that.
I understand what you mean.
So people who are interested
are much more willing to work
on the communication as a
destination, not as a source.
And breadth, a broad range
of experience in the world,
is the thing that fuels that.
If I've studied art, even though
I am primarily a programmer,
I've got an edge.
I'm gonna be able much more readily,
to be able to talk to the artist
and understand what their issues are.
And out of that naturally comes
a rekindling of my interest
in the things that they're passionate
about, depth, breadth, communication.
The most important of these
four, is collaboration.
People always say, yeah
collaboration is a great thing.
We want lots of that stuff.
Well what do you mean by that?
Well it's a really
cooperative kind of a thing.
Well what's the difference?
Well it's like cooperation on
steroids, that's collaboration.
It's really, really.
Now they've got to
mean different things.
Cooperation for us at Pixar is
that thing that is a definition
of a protocol that allows you
not to get in each other's way.
Think of an assembly line as the
quintessential cooperative activity.
The guy that puts the fender on at
Station 1, has to do a good job.
And the lady that puts the
headlight on in Station 2,
well the guy's job
on Station 1 matters.
But in a sense, a cooperative
enterprise could in some way be done
as long as you had enough time or
other resources, by a single person.
I put the fender on and then I walk
down here and I put the headlight on.
There's nothing about
the way job one is done
that makes the person
doing job two better.
They can prevent job two from being
done as well as it could be done,
but there's nothing in the
process that's optimizing that.
Collaboration has to
mean something different.
It can't be a synonym
for cooperation.
Collaboration for Pixar
means amplification.
The amplification you get by
connecting up a bunch of human beings
who are listening to each
other, interested in each other,
bring separate depth to the problem,
bring breadth that gives them
interest in the entire solution,
allows them to communicate on
multiple different levels, verbally,
in writing, in feeling, in acting, in
pictures; and in all of those ways,
finding the most articulate way
to get a high fidelity notion
across to a broad range of people
so they can each pull
on the right lever.
And the most amazing
things about school,
is that we have this
untapped resource in a sense.
Our students are the solution.
They're also the problem.
But there is an opportunity there
if we can find ways of invigorating
that leadership on our campuses,
that some of the problems
may get well on their own.
And then we can focus on
those things that you know are
on the table, that
you have to handle.
>>For more information on what works
in public education,
got to edutopia.org.